what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
players stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion
I'm Bellini and in this show I will
never cut my hair sorry sorry I'm late
hello I'm I am very happy for Lucca that
he won the Ballon d'Or what Phil Jones
and nobody wants to face me wait I've
taught this way my career at the time
with Aldo not moving here together a
David Beckham
fitness it was seven years before we
even started copying each other oh
really
Stowe easy-peasy now brough just hit
this anywhere on the board
and we win brilliant Morris now can you
turn the lights back on
Neymar he's been murdered one might be
an Emer what kind of animal would do
this Soares I am a biter
that's my thing I bite this guy he was
stabbed this is a backstabbing and who
is the biggest backstabber of them all
[Music]
Mauro he called it he could take a man's
wife he can take a man's life and he
does it with a knife okay hold on the
only crime I am guilty of is falling in
love okay yes with my friend's wife and
then marrying her and then getting a
tattoo of his three kids okay yeah it's
messed up I get it but I only
metaphorically backstab
whoever did this is someone a real
history of violence someone like Sergio
Ramos
is that man I was with model time it's
true unfortunately nothing else to say
and besides I have no reason to kill
NEMA unlike Coutinho what yes you the
Dark Wizard who wishes to have Neymar's
place as the crown jewel of El Camino
this is ridiculous me stop it first of
all why is no one accusing Ronaldo I
mean it's a little weird that he's not
here right and we know that what that
mean is if anyone wants Neymar out of
the way it's Cavani it's no secret
they've had problems and it appears he
has fixed them by murdering him except
he did not know because I am Thomas
Muller the wrong doctor also known as
the space investigator I thought it was
space interpreter there's no proper
English translation but really both a
valid it's very cool actually room
locked the doors to the rommel ooh I
mean Rama Lulu covers the doors I mean
never mind I will now investigate the
space hey talk about the Mahler
investigation am i right yeah you see it
could not become unny because a cunning
a murderer like this requires an elite
attacker
I mean alleged attacker ah you're very
good but cease was done by one of the
best
yeah well I'm definitely one of the best
so I think I should be a suspect the
real perpetrator is someone who has worn
the red and blue but not anymore you see
this person shouldn't even be at the
Champions League house show yourself
slaughtered true ha ha
I am the best player in the world that
is not what I said but I am NOT here to
murder I am here to take what is
rightfully mine
preparing are not as easy when you're
not in America anymore
enough with this we all know who the
murderer is it is Paul oh my god enough
with the I hate all Act
but fit who was the last person named I
was talking this before even dead I was
telling him the story of how I met my
fiancee and solves the crime who did it
nobody because Neymar is not dead he is
merely play-acting all to avoid small
talk miss hurricane and I would have
gotten away with it too if it weren't
for you pesky Germans and your technical
quality
[Music]
[Music]